hello there reject nation we got ourselves
an official trailer for the
latest predator movie prey
he's coming for you or she's coming
i don't know we are coming babe
yes gender neutral predator gender my predators
why do you want to hunt because you all think that
i can't huh okay i saw a sign in the sky i'm ready
pissed off that bear
like the edge for like the revenant
no oh [__]
you can't i'm trying to protect
you protect me from what
they're speaking english that's right man
they're assimilated
hmm
holy crap
it does look really sweet i know how to survive
oh my god
wow colonial guy kind of colonizer
i can kill it wow oh wow wowie
damn i can't wait to watch this on hulu that's
where this was meant to be seen on your phone
whoa the first predator trailer in a while that
really feels like this could be it this could be a
solid return to form here since you know the first
one man justice for predators it's okay and kind
of recaptures some of what you liked about the
first one well this really captures that uh great
level of suspense and tension and the way dan
trachtenberg director 10 club rafi elaine another
excellent movie by the way the way he handles
perspective in so many of the shots like i i'm
an animal lover i i gave up meat strictly because
of my love for animals so watching animals die on
screen is something that i'm really sensitive
to now that being said i was pretty badass the
way that she was doing at the same time with
the barrier it was like the way they captured
that from that reveal perspective of it being and
steal the motor just having this big ass bear move
that was a really awe and what a great way to
to set up the threat level of her not having any
real idea what she's dealing with really sets
up the obstacles this person has to overcome
and also with having to prove herself in her
own tribe with a like a really cool character
arc for her to go through okay in order for her
to i mean i feel like most of her her people are
going to end up getting killed off by the time
she can win the respect of the trap yeah so the
last guy will die the second he gives that single
nod of respect all right you're 100 officially
but no this this looks like every bit as just
immediate and visceral and you know punchy as you
would hope and i mean you know dan trachtenberg
what he did with 10 cloverfield lane in such a
restricted space was really cool and so i'm
excited to see the kind of tension he applies to
wide open spaces and the kind of claustrophobia
you can get from being out in a field or in the
woods or something like that yeah it just looks
lean and mean and really tangible and i feel like
being back in this time period i think they
said comanche nation is what they were taking
inspiration from you know i feel like that's
an appropriate way to go because you are in a
much more tangible realm it's not machine guns
and you know modern tech and i really just love
some of the imagery we got here like of them
walking through the woods at night with torches
and things like that like this looks like it could
be as intense as you're wanting it to be but also
have some really gripping uh visuals as well you
know some really striking you know use of its time
and place that way are we gonna be getting some
like english settlers i thought i saw some yeah
some dudes with guns and muskets and stuff
yeah and i bet they're gonna be made out to be
[__] they're gonna step in and they'll be
like what how do we know what we're doing
let us take care of this and then you know musket
goes up three dots bluey you know pilgrims ain't
[__] i'm curious as to what level of cultural
relevancy this movie will attempt because i feel
like you could go just lean and mean and have that
be enough but i feel like you could also you know
throw in some commentary to make it a little more
rich but i do fully expect any colonial characters
just to be murked on the spot i mean i don't think
they need to throw in commentary i think they just
need to throw in authenticity of the depiction
of the commentary will just be whatever people
interpret from the fact that you've got a female
character and yeah no character predators standing
in for oppressive forces for the outside taking
their lives and land but also it's going to be
like historical fiction it seems like they'll be
dealing with too yeah because it has some moments
that feel like a little cheesy but that's predator
yeah cheese first pregnant movie has some cheesy
ass [__] in there man and this this you son of
a [__] this this definitely had a little bit
of cheesy moments it feels like that it'll earn
some of the that cool cheesy action versus what
happened before like this feels like what they
should have called another like it sucks that
i think this one has been flying under
the radar a little bit because a of the
reputation the predator franchise has developed
and b the fact is called prey not not even like
not even a prey a predator movie story yeah yeah
i feel like there are going to be people confused
and i i keep hoping perhaps that if this is good
maybe people will be like you go check out the new
predator movie what there's a new predator movie
yeah it's called prey but just check it out like
i'm glad they gave it a different title at the
same time i'm like yeah it's gonna mean an uphill
battle for you guys yeah yeah brand recognition
sad as i am to say that i mean the benefit for it
coming out on like something like hulu substitutes
direct to it here for you got the channel and
i'm looking forward to that yeah because this
looks pretty excellent um in spite of whatever
random cheese there is i wish they felt sure they
would go full-on commitment to just keeping them
in their native tongue i would love nothing more
than to have it be like full apocalypto just like
exactly speak the native language and just
subtitle it and please go from there they'd
really get those box office or who subscriptions
with that yes they would everyone who joins for
american productions with subtitles is the most
popular genre i mean there's parts of this i feel
like the revenant meet prey yeah totally what's
that because of the bear what's that yeah is that
movie called the edge with the the bear yeah any
nature movies with bears that's what this reminds
me of that's right that's all the bear moves
bear fight movies all right guys what did you
think about the prey trailer leave your thoughts
down below the trailer talk to you guys soon